[Music]
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
yeah like i was saying too because in
australia the restrictions are very very
harsh and i think at the start of it
it wasn't that i was happy but i kind of
took advantage because i'm like you know
what i'm gonna have a lot of time to do
my own thing learn a new skill spend
time with my my fiance and all this kind
of stuff but i think a year and a half
later it's like okay
i think this is enough it's good it's
getting to me now i'm gonna admit it
yeah
i believe it you know i think we have
all had the same reaction the same for
me when first when it started it was
kind of like okay we'll have some time
together as a family and
we'll also you know i'll be able to kind
of let's say because i wasn't traveling
anymore so i was able to invest in
different venues that i i hadn't you
know different things that i knew that i
need to put some time in but i hadn't
and so it was actually pretty fruitful
but by now i mean it's not as bad here
as it is there but right now you know
with these passports
and the scapegoating
and all of these kind of weird political
measures that are
coming to the fore it's becoming uh yeah
it's becoming more and more frightening
let's say because it's also at the same
time they keep telling us
that it doesn't matter if you're
vaccinated you stop to wear your mask
yourself to social distance and there's
going to be boosters and there's new
variants and so it's as if they're going
to have it all we'll have
we'll have quarantines we'll have
vaccines and social distancing and masks
and infinite boosters
so it's very uh yeah and for a disease
that kills like point
one percent of the population
i don't know i mean it feels like it's a
little bit of a stretch
and to destroy our democracies and to
completely change the very the very
mechanisms by which our societies
function
uh so it seems to me like there's
something else that's going on and that
it's not just about a disease that there
are other that there are other things at
play uh in this so
ah for sure and like i laugh because
it's like i don't know what else to do
at this point you know what i mean it's
getting so
it's getting so ridiculous and i think
now
more than ever it's like so much
divisiveness you know what i mean like
if you have a certain opinion it's like
you're a piece of crap how dare you
and it's very black or white communities
breaking down this kind of thing so i
want to ask you
what is the symbolism behind all this
like especially what's going on right
now is this related to revelations or is
that a stretch what's going on here
um i think it depends how you look at it
you know i think that it's not a stretch
if you understand the book of revelation
as uh
as a series of patterns you could say a
series of social patterns they kind of
manifest themselves and the idea of
revelation is that it's the final
version let's say the most complete
version of this pattern but if you
understand it more as these kind of
symbolic patterns that it just exists in
the world then
it's then in revelation you can actually
see
these types of moves that happen in
culture you know uh
the example the example i like to give
is for example in scripture there's an
image of a [ __ ] writing a beast
and this [ __ ] is all about mixture and
about trade and about kind of consuming
and this whole vision of uh of you know
that that's what a [ __ ] is right it's
just just about pleasure and it's just
about consuming it's just and it's all
about mixture and lack of identity and
all these things
and so and then it's sitting on a beast
which is interesting and this beast is
actually an image of of control of
civilization because the beast
is is uh is an alchemy an amalgamation
of all the ancient empires in scripture
there's these beasts that have that
represent different empires so you see
like this amalgamation of empire with
the [ __ ] on it um and and then the
scripture says that the beast kills the
[ __ ] at some point
and uh there's this whole sense that the
beast sets up an image of itself
and that this image brings about a kind
of state of control and the idea of
marking with an identity and that when
you mark the idea of marking with an
identity in a way that you can't escape
the idea that there is no remainder
there's nothing outside of the system
the system tries to be total it tries to
be complete and if the only thing you
can do basically is if you refuse to
participate in the system then you're
completely excluded right you can't buy
you can't sell you can't exist that you
don't have in existence basically and so
if you understand it that way then you
can kind of see these
these movements towards
towards i did let's say the idea
identification and the idea of tracking
and control
and the relationship
you know it seems like the vaccine is
maybe just a door into these systems of
control which are possible because of
technology
and as we see this kind of coming
through then we see
exactly what we see similar things to
what we see in scripture which is that
right now i was just watching a video of
some minister in nigeria saying that if
you're not vaccinated and you can't show
proof of vaccination you won't be able
to go to a bank you won't be able to go
to church
and so this is the next kind of the next
step where they're like inching towards
the idea that you can't participate in
society at all
if you haven't received this
this uh
this kind of sacrament of participation
in at the same time as they're telling
us that the sacramento participation
isn't as good as you thought and you're
gonna have to keep getting it every
three four months for for the rest of
your life like i would i don't know like
it's all very vague but um so it does it
does kind of bring about we don't have
to freak out necessarily and think like
this is it you know but it does the the
so the sword scripture can help you
understand
these patterns uh and understand
this relationship between
systems of control how they take over
after too much freedom you could say
something is too chaotic and too
too much goes too much in that direction
then after that system of control comes
and tries to clamp it down
um
yeah it's very like
like lately it's been so inverted i feel
like these times because at one stage at
least in australia
it's completely illegal for you to go to
church but you can pay a prostitute to
have sex
like that's fine you know what i mean
it's like wait wait wait wait i thought
this was all about like social
distancing all this kind of stuff
but i don't think that it's about that
no there's something else definitely
something else going on and people often
it's funny because people wonder what is
it and
people don't understand that power is
its own motivation there is no other
secret motivation except for power
and
you see that it's like the capacity for
and let's say the capacity for power
which comes into a kind of unholy union
with people's
desire to feel safe and you know
desire to to not to not be in danger
these two things kind of go together and
they they go together surprisingly well
because the more say the safer you are
the more afraid you are
and the more you feel like you're unsafe
this is really true you know it was
interesting because you know i lived in
uh in congo for four years
and uh my wife and i and my my son and i
my son and us we we actually lived in
local neighborhoods with congolese
people you know in the city of kinshasa
you know there were no other
westerners around it was just you know
so so we were we were kind of in the
life and we lived through the rhythms of
the life and the west like the kind of
westerners north americans and europeans
lived in these gated compounds that had
guards and had had all this
and they were far more afraid
than we were
because they were so safe and they felt
like the safety
now all of a sudden every little danger
becomes like an like this crazy thing
it's like no you're not supposed to ever
be in danger you're not supposed to ever
get sick you're not supposed to ever die
basically uh and this is just
that that's not true it's just a lie
it's just a basic lie about how we exist
in the world and how risk is just an
integral part of being human
the less risk we take the more we're
afraid of them
yeah i think that's why i really enjoy
traveling especially to third world
countries and kind of just getting
thrown into the unknown you know what i
mean i think it's
what i've noticed today those who are
like the most strict about you know like
getting the jab and lock down all this
kind of stuff it's usually those who
haven't really stepped outside their
bubble their whole life you know what i
mean and i find that very interesting
like like you said like when you feel so
safe and comfortable that's when you
kind of get more afraid of getting hurt
and taking risks and these kind of
things
yeah exactly and it's and it really is a
you know it's just a kind of it's kind
of a mode of being in which people
embark and there's something about the
mother like something about this kind of
devouring mother that that says you know
it's like i'm gonna protect you from all
danger i'm gonna make sure that nothing
happens to you that you're not gonna die
you're not gonna get sick you're not
going to hurt yourself and you're not
also gonna be in danger there'll be no
hate speech no one's gonna insult you
nobody's gonna hurt you no one's gonna
hurt your feelings it reminds me of my
mother
she's like a latina spanish moms are
very overprotective she's overprotective
yeah yeah i rebelled in my teenage years
kind of had the opposite effect of what
she intended but oh yeah you're like
okay i need to break free from this yeah
but imagine that now i'd assist at a
level of systems where you know and
people struggle to understand that
there's a relationship let's say with
the kind of
rise in social justice mentality that
was there several years ago and this
desire for safe spaces this desire to
not to not be triggered that they know
that that we're fragile
and that we need to be preserved in from
all kind of danger and now this this
situation with kobe is an extension like
a physical extension of something which
has been a social phenomenon for quite a
for quite a while now
so
is this like a start of a new age do you
think
i just want to say it's coming back you
know
i hope it's not a start of a new age i
mean for sure it does feel like
something similar happened in weimar
really you know because weimar was a
wild place like it was a wild crazy
place and uh there were all this kind of
let's say fluidity in identity and
fluidity and in roles and fluidity in
terms of taboos and all of this was all
kind of mixed up
and at some point
when there was a crisis
then
the only thing to do was to
overcompensate and to kind of clamp down
and create massive systems of control
and i think that this is what we're
kind of seeing is that this little
crisis
is just
becoming an opportunity for systems of
control to clamp down but you know i
mean it's hard not to also see that
there seems to be something
that is transnational about what's
happening
there seems to be patterns which are not
just about our own governments but that
seem to be kind of moving across
governments ways of speaking even
types of words people use you know for
example like this phrase that's now
popular the pandemic of the unvaccinated
uh you know it's being used by different
governments by different authorities in
different countries and you realize that
okay this it's not just you know it's
like if justin trudeau says it
and then you hear it in england and then
you hear it in other countries and you
realize okay i've also heard them say
similar
phrases like build back better and all
these phrases that we're using they have
this kind of weird vocabulary that is
transnational um and so that's also kind
of frightening it is frightening to
imagine
that
that there are patterns which are even
beyond our politics
and that and that are just going to
happen there's nothing we can do about
it like here the the covet passport in
quebec where where i am
i mean it didn't
it didn't get debated in parliament it
didn't didn't get debated legally it was
just
sad like this is it it was just mandated
completely in a like a directly
tyrannical way and there was no possible
way to discuss it with anybody there was
nothing to say it was just like this
we're gonna do and everybody just says
okay
he's the same it's like we're not a
democracy anymore it's like everybody's
just forgotten that we're supposed to be
democracy
protesting is illegal so you can't even
like voice your opinion on this stuff so
they shut you down
yeah well
here at least yet right now they don't
shut us down they just don't cover it um
we're not like leave the country we
haven't since march last year yeah you
guys it's crazy like you're not allowed
to protest at all not we're not allowed
to leave i can't leave the city i can't
leave five kilometers within my own
house i think now they did
uh like only one person per household
can go for a walk around the block
playgrounds shut down like it's yeah
it's
pretty i don't even know what to say
about that because it's like i think
it's going to end but then it just gets
extended again and again and again and
it's like
i don't know man
but i guess a positive out of this whole
thing is that it acts led me to read
revelations and uh go inwards and kind
of explore uh christianity because i
discovered your work many years ago and
i didn't even know what orthodoxy really
was
um and it's been very mind-blowing and
i've really
been delving deep into symbolism and i
love your pop culture videos
breaking down the patterns of movies and
why
we're so like obsessed with pop culture
and stuff like this uh for those
listening at home maybe for those who
aren't very
well versed in symbolism what is
symbolism and how do you
distinguish that from let's say jungian
archetypes
well it's a little bit related i'm not a
huge follower of jung but it's it's not
completely unrelated uh the way to the
best way to understand symbolism i think
in a modern world is to understand the
the problem of complexity which is that
when you look out at the world we see
things we see the world kind of
that they appear to us in a certain way
but if we're attentive and we think
about it we realize that every aspect of
the world that we see
is an infinitely complex
right from the glass that i'm drinking
of you know to the table in front of me
to the sounds that i hear
they
like the glass that i have in my hand is
is as complex as you like there's an
infinite amount of complexity in the
glass like it's made of multiple
multiple parts and multiple aspects
right your chair is made out of multiple
parts and so but there's a way in which
we are able to perceive unities
in this multiplicity right and so
there's a way in which unity kind of
comes out of multiplicity
and appears to us as a pattern
right and so reality is necessarily
patterned
for us to be able to even engage with it
we have to kind of
our consciousness has to engage with it
in its patterns and so that would be
maybe the first way to understand what
symbolism is which is that there's an
inevitability of patterns in the way we
encounter things now this is true for
objects it's true for
sounds it's true for everything but it's
ultimately true for the way in which we
engage with each other that is
we string a bunch of of words together a
bunch of facts together to create
narratives to create stories and those
stories need to have a pattern
and that pattern isn't arbitrary right
it's a it's a it's an objective pattern
that you can discern and it's the same
for images it's the same for the way we
remember things so for us to remember
something we have to condense all this
multiplicity into images that we can
remember so those images will also be
patterned and so the way we represent
things ends up being patterns so that's
really the basis of symbolism and the
idea is that you can study that and you
can understand it and there's also a
process by which you could say this way
that the symbolism is the pattern of
attention right it's the way that we
attend to the world
and those things would grab our
attention the most and for the longest
period of time
will remain
and the things that we that don't grab
our attention and that we don't remember
will kind of fade away
just like if someone tells you what
happened during their day and it's
really boring and no and it's just a
bunch of things that don't relate to
each other you're just going to forget
it but if someone tell you this crazy
thing that happened to him and he almost
fell off a cliff and then something
happened and he came up and then you're
going to remember it because it's going
to have something which gathers your
attention so in the same way all the
stories we've been telling each other
for the millennia that we've been around
those have almost like a like a natural
selection process by which those that
end up being preserved are the ones that
gather our attention the most so that's
why you can look at fairy tales and
religious stories and myths as
containing more of these condensed
patterns than let's say just a common
reality in which we exist but the common
reality in which you exist is also
pattern it's just not as distilled as
these patterns and so in the same manner
the way we interact with each other is
also pattern right you speak i speak
we kind of have a way to listen to the
other person to show them we're
listening and we have to follow that
pattern or else communication breaks
down but then that also scales up into
rituals like handshakes like saying
hello you know like smiling and then
ultimately that scales up into something
like religious rituals where we all
gather together we act in communion we
act together towards something which
transcends us and then that binds us as
a community so we can understand
everything from fairy tales to
let's say to to to liturgy to christian
liturgy or to architecture with these
patterns of this kind of symbolic
patterning hmm
and
uh these patterns or symbolism is it
religious in nature like
well it's not it's
i would say you could say yes and no
that is it isn't religious in nature if
you you it's just reality but it's just
the way that reality lays itself out but
you could say that at the at a most
basic level reality does present itself
in a religious manner that is even if
you understand what religion the word
religion religion means
means bringing together means binding
together that's what really connecting
things together that's what religion is
and so it ends up being
the ultimate types of of patterns
move towards religion because they end
up being
let's say recognizing how these patterns
bind us together and then looking up
towards them
you could say consciousnesses it's not
just even pattern even consciousness has
this pattern and so you have something
which binds the community together they
recognize it they celebrate it together
they sing songs about it you know they
they they end up giving things to it you
know and so then you have the image of
the king or the image of a god and the
image of of of these heroes that we
venerate from antiquity and so it ends
up it does end up looking religious in
its kind of ultimate sphere but it
scales all the way down to like i said a
handshake or uh yeah or just kind of
simple social rituals
so are these patterns something that we
recognize
in our own minds or is the pattern a
more fundamental reality
well this is where it becomes tricky
because there's a there's a even today
like in modern physics right now you
know they have this whole observer
problem
and
they have
they have this sense a lot of scientists
even now are coming to the sense that
some
how
consciousness is necessary
for reality to kind of present itself
because or else without that we have
something like quantum fields or just
just this kind of possibility of
existence and so you can't completely
disassociate
mind from the manner in which reality
becomes pattern because it is kind of an
invisible
pattern which manifests itself in in in
reality so you can't completely
distinguish it the problem we have is
that since
let's say since romanticism and since
you know kind of modern philosophy we
tend to somehow think that mind is
subjective in the sense of idiosyncratic
and like you know relative to you like
relative to your opinion let's say yes
that's not that's not true they say
there's there's something objective
about mind and the way in which these
patterns present themselves to us
and in that in that objectivity then we
can kind of recognize them we don't just
recognize them we participate in them
and that's really important to see the
difference also between a kind of
symbolic understanding and a more modern
rationalistic
uh abstract way of understanding the
modern rationalists tends to abstract
themselves from the world and think
they're they don't exist or
they're just this like floating being
that's looking at the world and then
they analyze it whereas in when you
understand this patterning you realize
that no you're in the world and you're
kind of recognizing and participating
and celebrating these patterns rather
than this kind of cold uh cold cynical
uh that's cynical but like just cold
analysis of uh
of of science let's say um
do you think it's possible to step
outside
the patterns no and the world no
a lot of that a lot
yeah so i think so like oh you could say
that yes
um
but
how do you so but it would be something
like a spiritual like a spiritual
experience i think that you can have a
kind of transcendent spiritual
experience but that transcendent
spiritual experience will then when it
comes back down
right so let's say you have a a
theophany and you see
something you like you see with your
eyes but like you have an intuition it's
pure intuition of something which is
beyond uh
multiplicity
like as soon as you turn back
and you even think about it or even
represent it in your mind or you even
talk about it or you frame it then it
comes back into the world of patterns
um
does that make sense like it immediately
comes back into the world of patterns
and so uh so that's why
you can recognize uh like this i think
you can recognize a a fake spiritual
person from a real spiritual person when
the fake spiritual person tends to want
to destroy the world and so they go they
say they had this kind of spiritual
experience and then what they do
is they say
then they tried to relativize everything
it's like
i had the spiritual experience it and
then everything else is crap like
nothing
all of this is nothing right whereas i
think the real kind of spiritual
insight
is able to see that this is the source
of the patterns this invisible
transcendent point is the source of the
patterns and so he's able to kind of
gather them into
their experience there's a there's a
beautiful image in the
in a mystical christian mystical book
called the uh the life of moses by saint
gregory abnessa
describes moses ascending the mountain
in order to encounter god in the in the
divine darkness like even beyond light
into this kind of ultimate ultimate
transcendent space where even let's say
even vision disappears and you you enter
in this kind of pure
being let's say a pure beyond being so
as he goes up the mountain he removes
all these layers you know like his
sandals and he kind of removes this
quantity and becomes purified as he
enters into this kind of transcendent
space but then when he gets there
he's given the pattern of the tabernacle
he's given the pattern of the space of
worship
and so and in that pattern he sees all
the things he dropped
as he was going up right he sees these
layers he sees these garments of skin he
sees these actions and so that's the
idea is that if you really atten attain
these kind of high spiritual states then
you you should be able to gather into
them
the multiplicity and see multiplicity as
an expression of these high spiritual
states
hmm
i don't know if that makes sense to you
no no it definitely does i think it's
important to reconcile these worlds
because uh
i i fell into the kind of new age
non-dual track and it's not even real
non-duality really because what i've
found out is that orthodox christianity
is a form of non-duality because
non-duality just means non not two
uh
but yeah i did find this kind of
this path that a lot of people go down
uh in spirituality where they basically
try to dissolve the world
you know what i mean they call it
illusory it's all relativistic but what
i've experienced is absolute truth so
it's like this dialectical
tension like you're saying one thing but
then you're acting in a way that's not
really
congruent to what you're actually
speaking so you can't really
live and act in the world that you're
you're speaking about and
what are your thoughts about this like
this kind of
the the blind leading the blind false
prophets new age spirituality why is
this so popular and i understand it
because i went full force into it as
well and got a bit
well let's say first of all to give you
know as we say to give the devil to do
or to kind of understand what happened
is that yes christianity became
extremely superficial
oh you know from the time of the
enlightenment as it slowly moved
let's say towards the 20th century there
was this there was an extremely kind of
superficial and almost materialistic
version of christianity
what do you mean by that how did it turn
materialistic
well it became very moralistic first of
all it tended to discount mystical
experience it tended to be legalistic
right into this kind of protestant idea
that you're declared saved and it's this
kind of
uh it's kind of it's almost like a legal
declaration of your salvation and it
doesn't change anything really but it's
like when you die you go to heaven like
all this kind of nonsense you know so if
you believe in jesus you're done you
don't have to yeah exactly
that's what spirituality is to you it's
like you just believe in jesus and
you're saved
and that's it that's it like i don't
know what that is like i it doesn't mean
anything no so i get it right i
understand and then also the this
this one this desire to kind of embrace
uh scientism let's say in christianity
and then trying to kind of defend
scripture in a scientific way and defend
genesis as a scientific narrative and
defend all these stories in a historical
scientific way
and debasing them so much that they just
people didn't understand the spiritual
significance of these stories anymore
they would argue about some stupid
statuette that they found the desert in
palestine but then they didn't
understand what it even meant for moses
to go up the mountain and encounter this
divine uh transcendent uh experience and
then come down with his face shining in
glory like do you understand what that's
referring to or do you just see it as a
material phenomena that happened right
so this is the problem that that
happened and so
as the scientism and this kind of
materialism took shape and christians
tried to keep up and try to stay
materialistic at some point it just
shattered and then all these stories
just seemed like a much a silly stupid
story it's like why would it matter that
some guy got nailed on a cross 2000
years ago like that saves you like some
guy gets nailed on a cross
and then you're going to have it like
really i understand yeah that didn't
that didn't make sense to me either
right like is that the story like dude
it's just total nonsense right and so
it's like so i get it i understand why
at some point
people and you see it like you see it
even before the modern world you see
these um kind of esoteric
uh
these esoteric groups and these esoteric
uh ideas start to appear even in the
17th century you know you see with the
rosy cru rosy crucians and then moving
into kind of blobatsky and the
theosophists kind of you have this kind
of opening up and crowley and all these
occultists in the 19th century so you
kind of see this this reaction let's say
to this materialist moralistic uh
christianity and then that kind of wins
you could say in the 60s especially
that side of the of this of this kind of
uh conflict wins and then there's this
explosion of
kind of wild mysticism and all these
explorations of all these other
traditions and a mixture and like being
you know going to india to find some
guru and then
being fascinated by anything except your
own
your own tradition um and also like the
individualism of the modern world kind
of seeped into there and so it became
very idiosyncratic all the everybody has
their own thing and everybody has their
own mixture of stone of like you know
crystals and
these different practices and spiritual
whatever with all these things yeah um
and so i get it i get it but i think
that
it's important to kind of be able to
notice that
it's it's participating in the breakdown
of our societies right so you have all
these idiosyncratic spiritualities that
don't coalesce that don't kind of come
together
or they do as a cult so it's either
you're totally idiosyncratic
or you kind of give yourself completely
to this guru that usually lasts a few
years then it collapses and there's all
these scandals that come out and and so
it's a just kind of this this
it's a very disturbing situation and one
of the things that makes it even more
disturbing is really the obsession with
uh strange that is the idea that my own
story is worthless and i can't see any
value in it but i can read some like
weird tantric text from
from some culture that i have nothing to
do with that has a caste system that i
don't participate in that has that has
all these realities that i can't at all
understand but i find it super
interesting and super fascinating and
really uh
uh kind of uh i feel like it reveals
something to me uh so my like let's say
my
take on that or my approach to that is
rather than to say okay
let's go back into our story
and let's try to
go back and find find what was there
before the breakdown find what was there
before things started to fall apart
and that's what we see in
in the mystics like you read like i
talked about sangre of nisa there are
these amazing texts written in the in
the early
centuries of christianity
which have everything of anything that a
new ager would want in terms of this
kind of cosmic understanding and this
mystical union with something
transcendent it's all there but it
doesn't have to break down into all
these kind of uh
individualistic idiosyncrasies that
people participate in um and leads them
leads them into all these strange
directions you know
yeah i think i can understand the allure
i think with new age spirituality
especially with the you know the
understanding of the 19th 20th century
of christianity that materialistic
surface-level christianity you were
talking about and i can see why people
get so attracted to that eastern
mysticism side because you can have that
direct
mystical experience it's a lot more i
guess entertaining you know a lot more
explorations kind of scratches our
curiosity
button uh
and but like you said
early christianity like orthodoxy it's
got all of that mysticism stuff it's
just that we didn't we didn't know and a
lot of people who are very against
let's say christianity like protestism
or catholicism aren't even very aware of
orthodoxy and like no early church
fathers were teaching
exactly and not only that but there's
been an effort
in the past few hundred years to iron
over
in even in the bible that is even in the
bible translation there's been a
concerted effort to iron over anything
that smacks of something strange or
something that doesn't
that that that modernist can't deal with
you know and so
for example like this whole idea of this
hierarchy of angels and all of these
kind of sons of god that are in the
council of the divine and
and uh and kind of manifest god's will
in the world
you know that's something that people
have just been trying to chase out of
christianity for several hundred years
and kind of to their detriment because
now people are interested
everybody's interested in angiology and
everybody's like encountering all these
different angels but they have no way of
discerning what they're encountering
that's completely chaotic and they think
that just because they have an encounter
with a being that somehow this is
meaningful and not and and it's like so
they don't have a map to kind of
function in this world of intermediary
spirits but that's all it's all there
it's there in scripture it's there in
the tradition it's there in the
iconography of christianity where you do
have a kind of map of this intermediary
world and there are ways to kind of
encounter it held in a healthy way
without you know
ending up following some
some strange being that you encountered
on ayahuasca and then you and then it
takes you on down a very dark uh rabbit
hole and you find yourself
in psychic trouble you know after a
little while where all of a sudden you
start to break down oh yeah i've been
there man i've been there
it's scary scary stuff uh i think the
having grounding is really important
especially like strong scaffolding i
think when you just get catapulted into
these realms
sometimes it's hard to
close those doors you know once opened
yeah and the thing with doors is that
it's a two-way street exactly
it's not just you entering
the spiritual realm it's also spiritual
realm entering your if you believe in
that i definitely
i find it hard not to believe that there
is a spiritual war out there and there
are principalities so like what what are
your thoughts on this like pre-less
spiritual war good versus evil how do
you reconcile
dualism is it two independent forces
like how how do you
how do you go about this this is an
interesting there's an interesting um
way to kind of understand that which is
that
there is a kind of duality let's say and
the duality is due to the fall like no
matter how you kind of understand it if
you look at the story of adam and eve
that's what you see you see
that they're
in a kind of balanced space or in this
garden that is kind of a balance between
culture and nature that's a bounce
between masculine feminine that has this
this balanced reality uh
it's not perfect right and there's a
remainder in it which is this kind of
serpent and then this remainder tends
them into duality tempt them into
seeing duality as final but duality
exists right it exists in the world and
so that's the fall the false kind is
this fall into kind of extreme duality
and so you can see it in the human in
the human world as this kind of good and
evil and these kind of dualities but you
can also see it in the cosmic sphere as
these
two sides like you said the angels and
the demons are these two sides of a
great cosmic story
but there's also a manner in which these
principalities ultimately
are resolved in god and so there's a
there's an interesting uh quote from the
from the i think it's from saint gregory
nazianzus who he talks about the angels
of the left hand right that there are
the angels of the right hand and then
there are the angels of the left hand
the angels of the left hand of god are
basically the demons
and the demons
think that they're doing
their own thing but they don't realize
that they're not that they're actually
ultimately doing the will of god
in kind of showing us our own
let's say uh
weaknesses and manifesting these these
weaknesses and this darkness in the
world so that that darkness can then be
covered by god ultimately in the final
okay in the finals image you could say
it sounds like a relates a little bit to
jungian shadow integration a little bit
there's something of that but the
difference i would say with the shadow
integration is that
we really don't
we don't see
christianity that's really important
christianity doesn't see uh
darkness or doesn't see sin as a
positive force
it's a it's a uh
what it what it is it's a kind of um
it's something not in its right place or
something not looking in the right
direction that's what sin is and so
being is always positive like being is
always true but then there's an there's
a way in which it can become out of
whack
by
let's say attracting too much attention
to itself or not being in the right
place and so
that is the way in which you kind of
understand so that's the kind of the
joke about the demons is that
they think that they're dark but
ultimately they'll participate in the
greater light you could say without
without even understanding what they're
doing you know so it's not just it's not
that that god is integrating
non-being let's say or or this kind of
lack of of being but rather that he's
revealing the way in which things
actually do participate
in the great in the great picture um i
don't know that that makes sense so it's
kind of like the image of christ like
you have this image of uh
of christ going when christ dies you
know there's this kind of more
mythological version of the story in the
in the gospel of uh of nicodemus where
you know you have the devil and hades in
in hell and they're like we won right we
killed the son of god like this is it
you know we finally did it and they're
they're like excited because here he
comes right we're gonna bring him into
death but then they don't realize that
if you bring light into darkness
right it's not it's not light it goes
away it's you do the opposite and so
bringing you know god into death was
actually kind of revealing the
revealing the world and kind of
scattering that darkness um
well it's even like the a physical
example of
a candle light you know no matter how
much darkness there is around it it
can't actually overpower and over
consume it
no exactly that's the and that's a good
the the and the phrase you used is
exactly the phrase that saint john uses
in the gospel right he says the you know
the dogma did not know it but it it
didn't it couldn't overpower it because
like you said that's not how light and
dark work
hmm
and
even in pop culture or actually forever
we've been obsessed with the story of
good versus evil and the hero's journey
and all this kind of stuff and i
remember listening to an old podcast of
yours and you talked about the hero's
journey and how ultimately it's christ's
story
and that before christ there really
wasn't at least the version of the
hero's journey that is out today
is that true and can you like get into
that i mean i think so i i think that
because one of the things people talk
about is like the dying and rising god
that they're all these ancient stories
of these
pagan gods that that point towards
ultimately this kind of story of death
and resurrection uh but i think they're
i think they're kind of how can i say
this i think they're looking back from a
christian point of view into something
which maybe didn't have the same type of
hierarchy that they think it did that
there was these scattered these you
could say these scattered lights that
were in the world but then
from the story of christ then we can
look back into react into the past and
then all of a sudden we see these little
sparking lights that are pointing
towards ultimately what is the story of
christ
and so
the idea of going into the underworld
right this descent into the underworld
that's the story that you see uh in the
hero's journey but you also see just
in so many stories you see it in the
iliad you see in
in so many myths you know when you see
it uh in the aeneid all of these these
stories have this kind of descent into
hades and then
either you encounter someone you
encounter your father and then your
father reveals something to you or you
go there to get someone right uh you
have um
you have the story of i think it's
hercules who goes down into hades and is
able to save his friend out of out of
death and so you have these like these
little versions of this kind of going
into death and bringing out you know
kind of revealing something that wasn't
that death wasn't able to to hold on to
you could say or finding something
precious hitting in death like going
into death and then finding some some
vision that will give you meaning right
and so
so it's there right it is there but as
once the story of christ happens then
that
story is
it reaches its limit like there's no
there's actually no other story you
could say after the story of christ
because
in the fullness of the story of christ
you have this idea that
christ does that right christ goes into
death he doesn't just go into death
right he actually dies he dies he goes
into death then when he goes down there
he gathers everybody that's there
and takes them out
wow and so right we have this this
sentence we hear every easter in the
orthodox church which says you know
haiti hell is empty
like hell has been has been emptied by
christ christ went down and brought all
i mean it's mysterious it's not it's
hard to kind of completely
understand it but it is this image that
christ defeated death itself
and that by going into the underworld
when he came back out
you know that was it and so there's no
it's like i said it's the limit of the
story so you go down into the underworld
you solve the underworld and then you
transform it into glory and then that's
it like there's no
there's no version which can go beyond
let's say that version in terms of
categories
yeah it's it's actually it's a very
obviously a story an archetype that
resonates with so many people you know
yeah and even something like i didn't
want to talk a little bit actually about
lord of the rings because one of my
favorite movies and it's obviously a
movie that just exploded in popularity
and then i found out years later that
you know the author is a devout catholic
so it's got deep
christian symbology and i feel like a
lot of people
don't even notice but then they they
become super religious about lord of the
rings even 80s which i find quite ironic
uh why do you think lord of the rings
connected with so many people
and like what are the main kind of
powerful some symbolism behind that well
i think that i mean what token was able
to do is to really reinstate a you could
say an ancient vision of reality an
ancient uh cosmic image
and because maybe because he did it in
fiction
people didn't feel threatened by it
maybe something like that and so because
of that they were able to just
be seduced by it you could say and so
people
you know the most materialistic nerd
scientific you know programmer guy will
just fall in love with lord of the rings
and he don't doesn't totally understand
why if you ask him about religion he'll
say religion is stupid and superstitious
it's it's it's all these things but
nonetheless he he is able to be
completely kind of engaged and subsumed
by this story which has this this entire
kind of hierarchy of beings that you
know that moves from i mean in the lord
of the rings themselves doesn't
necessarily talk about the first god but
like it kind of moves down at least in
in the middle earth through the elves
and then the humans and then the dwarves
you know and then the orcs and so you
have this this kind of movement from
from light and kind of immortality into
this kind of monstrous uh darkness which
is at the bottom of the world and in the
movie they captured it so well like they
just do it so well because they have the
guy like coming out of the earth you
know and they're all like filled with
they're all scummy and dirty
and that music as well so almost exactly
like it's very it's super well done and
so because of that people just feel like
it's right even though it's completely
silly for a materialist to think about
elves and orcs and dwarves and all of
these all of these uh tropes they're
they're because they're patterning
themselves on just like in a traditional
image of angels above and demons below
and the men in the middle and the king
and you know the uh the
these kind of prophet uh priestly
figures like gandalf that have more
wisdom and they're able to kind of
manifest it to us like you know all of
these tropes and also the fall with
gollum who becomes obsessed and then
and then turns into
it comes closer to the orcs you could
say you know becomes demonized because
he's obsessed with with with something
which can which can kind of give him
power and so it's like we totally
recognize these truths but they're
really really just tropes right they're
really they're really uh they're it's
really a religious story
um
but it's great because it it's actually
for people that are attending to it they
can say well you know like i can i can
talk to you about the story that's in
the bible in a similar way
because it's way more than lord of the
rings like the story of the bible is is
is way more
has way more complexity and subtlety and
has all these layers in it and and all
these patterns playing themselves out in
different forms then lord of the rings
um because of that it's actually harder
sometimes because it's so big that it's
hard to it's hard to kind of fully get
what's going on it's very overwhelming
sometimes i'll open scripture i'm like
man this is exactly what i said
throughout my reading
you just fall into some weird thing
especially if you open the world at a
time
yeah so like some like weird law about
not mixing you know a donkey and a cow
while you're plowing your field and like
what are all these stupid things
how do you reconcile this man you know
that's why i i got the orthodox study
bible so that really helped kind of fill
in the gaps a little bit you know not
pretending like i i understand scripture
of course not i'm still an infant but
definitely saved me some time
uh but it's funny what you're saying
about lord of the rings you know people
get so
i wouldn't even go as far to say that
religious about it you know what i mean
like the nerds are like
crazy about it and it's funny how like
we even use it in our language now like
if you go on an epic adventure it's like
all right we're going on a lord of the
rings adventure you know or if you
instead of using the word hell like oh
man i went down to mordor last night
yeah devoured by orcs you know it's just
like things like it's just funny how we
use it in our language and it's like
it's metaphorical but it also kind of
reflects this very fundamental pattern
of reality
you know yeah that we and the movies
were really successful i think in terms
of visuals they really captured it still
holds up it still holds up today it
holds up i watched it just a few months
ago too with my kids because they hadn't
seen it yet and uh yeah it just it
really does hold up in terms of the this
this kind of world that exists and and
these different characters
uh you know yeah it it does pretty well
i was reading a few months ago i was
actually reading your your brother's
book on the symbolism of genesis
and i kind of wanted to unpack that just
a little bit maybe for those especially
who aren't too well versed in these
topics but
uh before getting into genesis i want to
know what is the
difference between this literal and
symbolic interpretation of scripture
like how should we even approach this
thing because i get that question a few
times like all the time take it
literally or do you take it
metaphorically and it's always we live
in a very dialectic culture you know
it's always has to be this or that is it
one or is it zero like what's your
answer for this well my answer is that i
just cut through all that crap like i i
don't like those i don't like that
opposition i i find that it's a it's a
dishonest opposition because if you
remember the way that i talked about
what symbolism is like symbolism is the
actual pattern
by which you're able to attend to
something
so it's so so it's actually it's so it's
the pattern of a story it's the pattern
of an image it's the pattern because
let's say you take the story of of
christ you know christ i don't know
christ uh at the wedding of kana
you know there's a million things that
were happening in that event
there were indefinite amount of things
happening at the same time in that place
and not with standing around it
right it's like there was you know
there's crinkled in in his robe there
was you know dirt on his sandals there
was there's a mill like billions and
billions of things happening
and so in order for you to be able to
attend to what was happening and to get
meaning from it you have to condense
those facts into a narrative you have to
choose facts
and then you have to string them
together in a way that i will recognize
that this is a union and so even the
literal
meaning of a text is already symbolic
hmm it's all it's necessarily symbolic
because why did we why are we talking
about this rather than that
why am i mentioning these facts and why
am i putting them together
in a narrative that i can recognize and
so there is no neutral reality there is
no neutral meaningless reality that's
just there and then on top of that
i add some metaphorical meaning that's
just total nonsense
there's already a reason why that story
is there there's a there's a reason why
the story is constructed the way it is
and that those facts have been chosen to
be sequenced in that manner and so the
meaning is already there at the very
first left layer right and so the best
way to understand is that what you would
think as literal just means that you're
very paying very close attention to what
the text is saying right that's even
what literal means literal means
literature it means what's written
that's what literal used to me it means
what's written and so you you pay
attention to what's written you have
what's written there and then what's
written there is structured in a way
that is analogically related to other
things and then that's when what you
would call the metaphorical meaning will
appear to you which is that as you look
at the pattern of the story
you realize that it's structured in a
way
that is similar to
your experience that's similar to a
society that's similar to
another story in scripture and then a
story from mythology and so then you
that's when you get what maybe what
people call the metaphorical meaning
which is that i can take a story in
scripture which is already symbolic
which is already patterned in a cosmic
way and then i can say
this is similar to your experience and
then i'll apply it to your experience
and it's actually similar to the way
token understood storytelling because
token hated metaphorical meaning he said
he said my my stories i don't have
metaphorical meanings and people don't
understand what he meant and he said he
said they're not metaphorical they're
applicable
and so he said you can apply my stories
to things
but they don't it's not like you know
the orcs are the communists and and the
this aspect of the story is some other
political thing and then this is meets
technology and this it's like that's the
wrong way of looking at the bible and
it's it's the wrong way of reading token
too it's a it's mostly that the pattern
of the story of tokyo can be applied to
your experience or applied to a
situation and then you can use it as a
lens to see the world and so that's the
way in which scripture is metaphorical
but you won't find
like the idea of literal the way that
people think of literal that is a
neutral telling of a story that is
completely without meaning is absolute
nonsense it doesn't exist
yeah well you know like i said before so
i think we live into a polarizing
society it's very people very dialectic
on both the material side of things and
even the the kind of spiritual
absolutist
yeah person who you know like the
materials will
deny anything that's spiritual and
ground their reality from everything
below and then the spiritualist will
deny matter
altogether
yeah and say everything is one what does
that even mean what's what's everything
is one
i don't think
people who say that and also people who
talk about non-duality i used to say it
too
and then i realized looking back i'm
like wait that actually doesn't make any
nobody but nobody nobody dares believe
in non-duality at least the way they
think they do they think they believe in
non-duality and you're like you believe
in non-duality really do you eat your
feces no you don't eat your feces so
don't tell me you believe in non-duality
what are you talking what are you even
talking about why does eating your crap
relate to
non-duality well because you don't eat
your crab because you believe in duality
you believe that some things are outside
and some things are inside and you don't
mix them together
right that's that's because you believe
in duality
you know you you live in a house you
wear clothes you you ha you you you
function in duality
constantly and you experience duality
and you live with duality and you don't
if you if you believe in absolute
non-duality in the way that especially
people want and especially in the way
that relativizes everything
then and there are like
there are there you can find traditions
that are cannibals you can find
traditions that that break all the
taboos but i'm not sure many people are
willing to go there because it's
actually very destructive you know these
kind of weird tantric traditions are
very destructive to reality you know
people most people don't want to destroy
reality they're lying when they say they
do because
they actually exist they exist they have
a life they have all these things and so
and so the idea is that
love is a better expression like love is
a better way to understand it because
love has
the notion of of ultimate non-duality in
the sense that we all participate in the
life of the infinite god but we're not
we don't it doesn't mean that everything
is relative and everything is illusion
it means that
because god loves us then we all exist
at the level that we do it's as if god's
infinite love
also kind of let's say moves out of
himself into this multiplicity
as he's gathering it back into himself
so it's not just like either everything
is an illusion we're all just you know
we're all just brahma like we're all
just drops in the the you know the the
the this kind of vast like infinite
consciousness uh
it's rather like a balance between unity
and multiplicity right uh an
understanding that multiplicity exists
that it does but that ultimately for it
to even exist it has to participate in
the oneness um but when people just say
things like it's all one or whatever
like john lennon and that kind of
nonsense right he's like we could all be
as one what are you what are you talking
about
it's just it's just it's just uh just
posturing
there's no heaven
yeah yeah
oh yeah
that's when am i does that kick you off
yeah
he has some good stuff though i i i yeah
i don't really i mean i like to be
everybody likes it nobody everybody who
doesn't like the beatles yeah because i
like the v-nose but uh that song in
particular yeah but it's it's ironic
because like you're talking about
these people who claim to have this
absolute experience and that god is
absolute everything and literally every
single particle in the universe is god
everything in physical reality is just
an illusion but then they're basing
their
experience of the absolute
from a relativistic subjective
experience so it's like this kind of
i don't know it's just this weirdness
because you're claiming absolute reality
but through a subjective lens anyway so
that you can't really escape that that
duality you know what i mean there's so
much wrong like if you really
if you really had an experience
that
that there's only the absolute
and all its manifestations are
complete illusions you know what you
would do you would shut up
because why are you speaking
what are you saying
yep
it's it's all that's why that's why you
realize that there's just a nonsense to
a lot of the a lot of this type of
posturing that you hear
in kind of in this kind of modern uh
spiritualist uh you know reality um
and it's not like you don't encounter
texts like that in the traditions like
there are there are texts or there are
traditions would do kind of
try to point to the manner in which
let's say compared to the infinite like
that the infinite is
something which is beyond duality that
that the infinite does kind of empty
itself in and contain everything at the
same time and there's a
language of aporia which people use to
to talk about that and you see that in
the in the even in in in religious
traditions but
like i said this also has to coexist
with all the more buffered versions of
that in which we also do participate in
which we do go to church we kneel we
sing we burn incense we we do all of
these celebrations
you know and we don't just have this one
this kind of esoteric vision of the
infinite that destroys reality because
that's the that's the problem with a lot
of this with a lot of this stuff is that
people just
say mysterious things they just say you
know that kind of stuff like you know
the universe is in a grain of sand and
the grain of sand is the whole universe
and you're like really is that really
you really think that i don't think you
do i think you're just bullshitting me
get those social media likes people like
to like to hear that yeah they like that
kind of that kind of fluffy stuff
yeah it's funny because like
i i started off doing new age stuff but
i feel like because i'm australian i
have that kind of inherent down-to-earth
casual sort of
relationship with it so i think it
wasn't as new age hippie but i think as
i got more grounded over time uh people
weren't very happy
with me
and it's really yeah well it's something
that i
i question because i find it weird how
in
this kind of world there is no word for
pre-list there is no word for
false spiritual experience and even that
is very triggering because like how dare
you say that my experience was false it
felt so overwhelmingly real and i've had
many of those i'm not even saying that
it's false or it's true but the fact
that there is no discernment between
them
how do you know but you don't have to
question the experience people have
you know it's mostly it's mostly like
you said the discernment of that
experience and so
you know in the orthodox tradition
i think it i think they have the really
good way of dealing with this which is
basically saying
you should ignore all spiritual
experiences and i know people are going
to go like what just ignore spiritual
experiences but that's that's what they
say and the reason why they say that is
because they realize that if you really
believe
even what a new age will say which is
something like you know the purpose of
reality is to be united with the one
right to be to kind of be united with
the transcendent uh reality then if
that's your purpose then that's what you
should be aiming towards and then these
spiritual experiences that you have
that's not it
right just because you see an angel or
you have some feeling or you have some
insight even if the inside is
true to a certain extent that's not your
goal that's not where you're headed so
you have to be careful not to not to
give too much attention to that because
you're going to uh you're going to stay
there and you're going to kind of turn
around in these like these kind of
experiences
and so if you just ignore the
experiences then there's less of a
danger of being you could say seduced by
a demon you know
or seduce something which is off-key
because you're just you're just kind of
and you will have the spiritual
experiences right you will but you just
don't you don't
spend your time on them and you don't uh
you don't wallow in them you could say
you rather keep your eye
on the ultimate goal which is you know
which is the union with the divide yeah
yeah and even test your experience you
know and see if it holds up over time if
it still makes cohesive sense with the
rest of your conception of yeah and also
the fruits you know yeah the french
know a tree by its fruits that is that
if you have these spiritual experiences
but you're a total jerk to everybody
around you and
and it's like
and you continue to to have all these
sins in your in your life and all these
things that are your obsessions and your
you know your idiosyncrasies then that
spiritual experience is pretty
meaningless
like it might have felt real and it
probably was real but it's not
moving you towards freedom it's not
moving you towards something which is
which is more than just a kind of uh
like like an entertaining experience you
could say
yeah
that's why integration is so important
like the work that you do afterwards
it's like kind of reading a book and not
contemplating you know what i mean it'll
just go right through your head except
that it's a little bit it can be a bit
more dangerous obviously going into
these realms and let's say reading a
book
yeah but i think i think a lot of it has
to do with
like naivety like you know what i mean
just overly trusting i found that the
people who are the most trusting
uh navigating through these spiritual
realms without actually taking it
seriously are like usually yeah just
kind of young white hippie
western people
uh who've never really i don't know
because i i grew up i've had some like
kind of rough experiences and i've met
people
during my teenage years like who are
very charismatic and they're very
actually good looking and handsome and
very you know what i mean like they know
how to talk to you and make you feel
good but then you find out later that
they're actually a snake
but you can see them go out in the rest
of the world like people being like oh
he's such a nice person but then when
you actually peek behind the curtain
you're like yeah i know that guy
johnny's a dick don't trust him
kind of thing so there's a lot of yeah
yeah
that makes that makes that makes a lot
of sense
um
and i think
you know i think there's also an aspect
of materialism which is part of that
which is that because we've been so
hounded and we're hounded in school and
we're told that the world is just a
bunch of phenomena that can be
calculated and be
and be measured is that when people have
an insight that there's actually
something more
then it's like whatever that more is
they're all excited about it and they
just want to dive in and they want to
experience so it's like like you said it
also the materialism leads to this lack
of discernment as well because it's like
oh wow there's this whole world that
that they lied to me about that actually
does exist and so it's like open the
doors open and it's like oh there's
something there's something it's like
this fast you know everybody's just
excited about it but it's like no wait a
minute no no that's a that's a really
bad thing like that's a demon and that's
actually a projection of your passion
and that's a it's like and so but it's
at first people don't they don't have
that capacity because there used to be
complete materialists and so that's
probably one of the problems that we
have too you know it's yeah i i i relate
i went through that too um yeah and it
would even
maybe even some people listen to this
right now might be triggered for when
people even say oh it's a demon like all
right crazy christian fundamentalist
what do you even mean by that
i mean if demons are
it saying the role of god anyway why
does it matter yeah well
people recognize let's say let's say
let's let's give it a simple example
let's say you're you're addicted to
something i don't know i mean you you
drink too much or i don't know whatever
it is you watch porn or like you have
this addiction right and you know that
it's an addiction because it it because
you can't control it right
because you try to and then you can't
and then it kind of pulls you
and so
that's a principality that that's that's
also a principality that is it's it's a
pattern in reality
that is cosmic it's cosmic because
you're not the only person with that
addiction dude
there are other people that also have
that addiction it means that that's not
an idiosyncrasy to you it's not just
relative to you it's an actual real
pattern that exists in the world
but in which you are participating and
that that you are not only participating
but that you by engaging in these bad
habits and these behaviors you are
feeding it
you're sacrificing your time and your
attention to this pattern and you're
making it stronger in the world
because you're you're like a
you're a branch of it you're a body for
it you're you know your tool for it to
appear in the world right so it you
don't need like a ghostbusters way of
thinking like it doesn't have to be
something like a woo-woo science fiction
thing this is just cognitive reality of
how things work so that principality
has a cosmic version of it
it has to because it doesn't just exist
in you it exists in all these other
people and so that's a demon and you can
encounter it
and you can be possessed by it
and you can be a tool for it to spread
in the world like have you ever met
someone who has a bad habit and is
obsessed with getting other people to
participate in that very bad habit
oh why they even know they even know
that it's bad for them like if you if
you buy them a little you know that it's
destructive but nonetheless they want to
get that young kid to smoke and they're
they they secretly want to get these
teenagers to drink or to do whatever it
is that that they do
and so they're they're they're a tool of
this demon in the world it's a real
thing
i'm just getting flashbacks because like
you
it's so true like when people are so
entrenched in their bad habit let's say
whatever weed drugs and i've had these
experiences where
you're like no i don't want anymore it's
like just have one man just have one
just have one like they're like and they
even kind of physically transform into
that kind of awkward demonic like just
have one come on man just have one
and it's like dude no
and then as soon as you try to break
away from
their lifestyle then they get like
triggered and inflamed they're like what
do you mean what do you think you're
better than me you know it's like whoa
whoa whoa man i just didn't want to do
drugs that's all yeah no but you you've
got the exactly the you've understood
the right pattern and
so
so these so you can understand that
let's say let's say think about this so
there are principalities in the world
that are trying to get your attention
right there are some that are light and
there are some that are dark
and
you know like all the good things all
you know like loving your neighbor
helping your friends uh you know being
good to your spouse taking care of your
children there are all these light
these light
patterns in the world and they are
trying to kind of get your attention and
you want to give your attention to them
and then you have all these darker ones
that are there as well now you can
understand these these these patterns as
just
abstract patterns in the world but they
we are conscious beings like we are
persons
and those patterns end up
coagulating into something like persons
as well
and so that's why we in the same way
that i encounter you a pattern thing in
front of me right you're just a pattern
but i encounter your face and your
behavior
as a pattern being
that is the same for these higher
principalities
you know and so and so you can yeah you
can like i said you can encounter them
they can manifest themselves to you and
sometimes in a more immediate way
depending on people's sensibilities um
but even if they don't you can still
understand that they're acting on you
and and and you you know like let's say
i don't know if you've ever
you kind of free yourself from a bad
habit let's say yeah you have this bad
thing that you're that you're dealing
with and you're able to free yourself
from it um and then when you're kind of
free from it
you you're even like
like who is that guy
who is doing that you almost don't
recognize yourself like you look at
yourself and like who's that guy that
was doing this like how is it that he
was doing this and you're like you
almost like you don't even
there's something about it that you
can't even barely barely recognize of
course until the day that you're like in
a weak spot and then all of a sudden you
don't then again you don't know what's
going on and it's like
you know you wake up and you're like
back in the in the pattern and you're
thinking how did i get back here i
thought i was out of this thing like i
thought i wasn't in there anymore how
did i fall back
back into satan's den
exactly i said i'd never do this again
and you're waking up with like 10
hookers around you drugs you're like and
you're like what like how did i get here
exactly and so like but these
experiences are real like that
everybody's had them and so we can
understand them just in terms of uh
psychology but they're more than that
and and
you know ancient cultures and
and and christian culture was able to
recognize that this is not just
idiosyncratic to you these have
objective reality these patterns and
there are ways
to deal with them religiously and that
something even like exorcism can
actually have an effect on you
in the same way that a coach why is it
that a coach who speaks to you before a
game would make you better at playing
basketball do you think that's you don't
think that's stupid well why does it
bother you that maybe someone with
authority
could
with spiritual authority could affect
you in a way that would
free you at least somewhat from that
from these different bad patterns that
you have so there are all these ways to
kind of be able to look back and see
again these rituals these practices that
we see in in ancient culture and just
see how they they're totally coherent
they're not at all
they're not strange the way they people
told us they were
yeah yeah definitely and
what i really appreciate about the
trinitarian view of god is that well
three
the number three is actually the number
of reconciliations right it transcends
opposites and something i've been
searching for so many years because no
matter what
world view i came to there was always
this dialectical tension there's always
this or is that hermeticism actually did
a pretty good job of explaining uh like
transcending duality and uh dark and
lightness and all this kind of stuff and
even in hermeticism they
completely prove that you can't be god
because of this this and this
you know and i found that very
interesting because in this world today
we well
either you don't believe in god or you
believe you are god which is
mathematically the same thing right
yeah exactly now that makes a lot of
sense and that's what you you end up
seeing well we it's more like yeah we're
we think we're like little gods you know
and then we kind of act that way but
usually if you observe someone who
thinks that you realize that they're
just
they're just a series of possessed like
they're just possessed by all these
things you know and you kind of see them
pop up when you're looking when you're
watching someone and all of a sudden you
like oh oh oh here comes
here comes this thing like here it comes
and you got to see it coming it's easier
to see it in other people which is
horrible
but yeah but it it's true you can see it
you're with someone and all of a sudden
you can kind of see something coming out
you know of them some of some like
obsession or some weird way of
interacting with others like you for
example like
you you watch a you know you have a
friend a woman friend let's say
and then you know you're engaging you're
talking with her and then you go to a
party and all of a sudden you see her
like falling into like flirt mode and
you're like what that was she's like a
whole other creature and when she moves
and speaks exactly everything about her
and you're like what is this like who's
what's going on this is like this being
is is uh yeah is
it's not the same being that i was
dealing with you know an hour ago
yeah yeah
that's why i like to just
constantly remind myself i'm just human
i'm always infallible i'm always gonna
fall and it's fine it's actually quite
freeing to think that way versus you're
you are your own god and you can
basically bend reality to your will and
i'm sure you can for a little while but
i don't know man i feel like there's
always a price
for everything yeah it snaps back yeah
the building snaps back because
yeah there's 98 of you that you're not
aware of
so much of who you are you're not aware
of like
you know in the orthodox tradition
people wonder why that is but we we're
constantly confessing sins that we don't
realize we've done that we're constantly
saying
you know wittingly or unwittingly like
confessing the sins that i've done you
know on purpose or on accident because
there are aspects of my being that i'm
not even aware of and so people who
think that they're
that they're kind of like these little
gods they don't realize that they have
these little imps that are writing them
and and so they they kind of act and and
all of a sudden something happens like
you know this this aspect of themselves
that they hadn't accounted for you know
kind of springs forth
and uh yeah and then they get they get
sideswiped you know so
yeah that's why community is so
important you know having i say this all
the time but i think it's gonna it's
very important to have good friends that
will call you out on your bs oh yeah you
know instead of just being in your own
lone world having spiritual experiences
and yes gaining so much knowledge
just inhaling all that wisdom and you
just yes i'm god
yeah exactly and you keep recreating
that reality yeah yeah yeah exactly and
can't do normal human to human
interactions
yeah but i get it too but i actually
really wanted to dive into the
like the book your brother's book but
uh
just maybe for those who underwear
what is heaven
and earth
like how do you think okay so yeah so
maybe
my brother again just named for people
my brother is his name is mattir
so he has a similar name he wrote a book
called the language of creation
and uh my brother and i we both kind of
developed the symbolic thinking together
when we were in our 20s um and he i
would say he's kind of a he's a far
superior symbolist than i am in terms of
his kind of grasp of patterns and he's
almost kind of mathematical in his
in his in the way he sees things um and
so the way to understand uh
heaven and earth is almost in an
aristotelian way it's like there's
actuality and potential and there's or
you can see it like that there's
invisible
spiritual patterns
and then there is
the potential for them to manifest
themselves in multiplicity and so that's
what heaven and earth is it's light and
darkness right it's a good way to
understand that so light is that which
reveals
and then darkness is that which contains
the
the hidden bodies that will that will
kind of
sustain the light you could say um or
it's also
uh let's say
this idea of just invisible these
invisible
spirits like spirit is just wind in in
terms of the words and so you have this
kind of invisible movement
and then you have the waters below let's
say and so that's what that's what
heaven and earth is at least in
scripture but not just in scripture it's
the same heaven and earth that you find
in
uranus or in gaia or that you find in in
you know innate in the aboriginal
cosmologies and all these different
cosmologies it's it's a pretty universal
idea
yin and yang it's all that stuff
and how do you how do you reconcile the
kind of
physical afterlife place of heaven of
what it says in the bible
yeah well the bible doesn't say that you
go to heaven oh there you go
so there's a difference between paradise
and heaven
okay oh man i don't even think about
those yeah yeah i just assumed
so so paradise is the garden of eden
right and so
paradise is the paradise is the place
where the balance between heaven and
earth exists
it's the place between
where the patterns and the their balance
manifestation finds its its totality so
christians don't believe that we go to
heaven they shouldn't some people do but
we believe that we'll be resurrected
that that that chris the humans will be
resurrected and that they will become a
perfect union between the invisible and
the visible you could say
that's the way to kind of understand the
way that christians understand
spirituality now you do see
beings that go to heaven in scripture
for example elijah
ascends into heaven
christ ascends into heaven and you see
that you know saint paul talks about you
know it seems like he's talking about
himself saying that he went up to the
third heaven and so
heaven is this the place where
identities come from
and so it is possible for a being to
let's say move into heaven so a way to
understand it like let me give an
example of being going into heaven so
saints you could say to a certain extent
ascend into heaven
okay because then they become patrons of
things
and so let's say
a saint moves up
into heaven
and then now we have churches named
after the saints people will
ask this particular saint to intercede
for them regarding certain things let's
say say mary of egypt for example so say
mayor of egypt is the same people pray
to when they're having sexual
temptations and so she's become
she's she is to a certain extent in
heaven
because now
she's she is becoming like an angel in
the sense that she's like an invisible
pattern by which we now
congregate that we come together and
recognize and then we and then we also
kind of ask
for her to help us in this aspect of
reality i don't know that if that maybe
helps to understand a little bit the
difference yeah yeah
interesting yes i never even thought
about the distinction between like
paradise
and heaven but then there's also the
uh
like what your brother talked about in
the book about how heaven is abstract
principles basically and where the
purpose of humans are to inform meaning
with matter and express matter through
meaning if i remember correctly yeah
exactly yeah so that's exactly it so
it's like a two-way street it's like you
have these you have these principalities
which are invisible and are patterns and
then they find body
in in potential but then it's also
matter let's say
kind of expressing those
those principalities like you need both
of them to kind of happen together
because because the abstract principles
are useless without expression
yes
can the soul live without a body or is
it for it to exist that has to have some
sort of uh
it has to have some attachment to body
at least at least kind of
eschatologically like at least in the
totality of things it has to be attached
to a body except for of course god
doesn't
you can say everything is about
like god's body is is the entire cosmos
this may be a way to understand it but
it but uh you know even the angels are
said to have subtle bodies for example
that they don't have uh material bodies
but they have subtler bodies you know um
so a way to understand that is like a
very simple way very simple simple way
is that let's say you have an ideal
and you're like
you know
i don't know you're you're some guy
who's 250 pounds you know you you're
watching tv and and you decide that
you're going to become you know the
sprinting champion of the world
and then and it's like okay and you may
i know you're 50 years old
it's like that pattern that you're
looking towards can't
be embodied by you
it's actually not useful to you that
pattern is useless to you that ideal
that abstract let's say direction that
you're aiming towards
is is you can't embody it
and so you what you have you always have
to find
this relationship between
let's say the
the principles or the ideals or the
things we're aiming for and the capacity
we have to
embody them
but you can't you can't make a car
out of grass
it's not the proper body for that
pattern challenge the body of the body
of of a car has to
be able to express the car so matter has
to express
the principle and then principal and the
car the idea of a car is useless unless
you can drive it like i mean yeah it's
nice to think about the idea of a car
but unless you can drive it it doesn't
it's not going to have much use to so
you have to be able to find
reality is about finding the place where
these things join together
um
and how does uh how does christ join
together between the material and the
spiritual how does this
how does the kind of triune god
reconcile
all these paradoxes that we have
compared to let's say the idea of an
impersonal god or pantheism things like
this
well the idea like if you think about it
like a mountain you think about it like
a hierarchy and that's part of the
okay that's part of the
this the way in which the world kind of
lays itself out when i talk about the
pattern of attention this idea of kind
of moving
even the idea of moving towards the one
like as you're moving towards the one
that's what you're doing you're you're
moving out of quantity or or let's say
condensing quantity so that you move up
towards the towards the one which is at
the top right that's that's where one is
if the world is like a mountain
so that point
is something like
ultimately cosmically it would be the
fulcrum like the place
where heaven and earth meets
in a kind of absolute way and then all
the other places that heaven and earth
meet like the place where the idea of
the car and the actual car meet
that would be somehow a consequence or
down the hill from
this ultimate place where heaven and
earth meet and so the idea is that that
has different expressions in in uh in
scripture
you know the the mountain of paradise
the mountain of moses where he goes up
receives the law
the tabernacle where you go into the
holy of holies and you know you kind of
you move from the quantity of the people
into the one priest that goes into the
holy of holies and then
sees the glory of god so there are
different versions of that in scripture
and in not just in scripture but in
every religious tradition there's all
these different versions of it ziggurats
uh you know all these different images
and but then the idea that
what christians are trying to help
people see is that
that ultimately is
man first of all
right we are the place we're meeting
and
the invisibles we are like the
laboratory
where that happens
it's kind of through us
that meaning
appears in the world
and so that's the one thing that you
realize in someone like christ is that
ultimately man is that place where that
happens
but then
that man let's say the man that has that
position
will also manifest something
and what he'll manifest is that he'll
actually fill up the whole hierarchy
he won't just be the top
he will actually
contain the whole thing
in himself
and so if you want to understand the
story of christ that's what it is that's
why christ has to die that's why christ
is all these things if you look at the
way christ is represented he's you know
he's all these opposites actually you
know he's a he's described as a as a
as a farmer in the sense of
agriculturalist he's a he's also a
shepherd he's the king
he's uh
he's a priest
he's a workman
he's a slave he's a he's a he's a
criminal he's every aspect of reality
that is kind of packed into his story
and then that that
that kind of condensation of his story
and then it also like he he fills the
world up that's why he heals things like
he's always healing disease he's always
kind of let's say at the top of the
mountain and then healing that which is
below right going to the stranger
well that's why he goes to prostitutes
and republicans and all these marginal
figures because he's going to the edge
he's moving out and kind of gathering
all things into himself yeah he would
dream
he would drink with sinners right right
right
right
right
right
right
right right
right
right
right
right
right right right right right go into these
bars and just go to the satan's den hang
out with the homies
and so he was either yeah he was able to
do that without because he contains all
of this in himself he was able to do
that without losing himself you could
say like let's say most of us if i went
into a bar with a bunch of prostitutes
then maybe i would lose myself there
right maybe i wouldn't be the one to to
bring the prostitute into into the love
of god but i would rather you know
find myself being dragged out into the
into the den of hell and so that's the
difference between the way that christ
so when christ encounters the prostitute
you know she ends up you know washing
his feet out of compunction for her sins
and and and you know wants to transform
her life and so you see the same he goes
to a tax collector who are these
horrible
corrupt officials you know and
when he encounters them they're like i'm
gonna give my whole fortune to everybody
and i'm going to you know i'm going to
help the poor and i'm going to so it's
like christ transform all transforms all
these aspects of reality as he
encounters them so it's not just about
hanging out with the with the with the
people on the edge but it's actually
about transforming everything and
bringing it into himself so there's a
million examples of how he does that but
ultimately the death the death of christ
and the resurrection ends up being the
ultimate image of that like i said which
is that he goes down to the bottom of
reality
he goes all the way down into death
where everything is broken apart and
everything is fragmented into its
constitutive elements
and he then gathers all that up and then
rises up
resurrects
and then ascends into heaven
right but now by ascending into heaven
he's actually bringing everything into
heaven with him so it's an image of
gathering all of multiplicity all of
death all of this everything into god
and so that's that's what the
incarnation is about and it's something
which ultimately happens
in all eternity right it happened at a
moment in history but it's it's actually
happening it's something which is the
kind of a cosmic truth about how reality
works it's not just something that
happened it's actually revealing that
you know you could say that reality is
already and always reconciled in god and
that christ kind of
manifested it at one point in the story
but that this is actually how reality
works
hmm
there's a lot of you know old
mythical
stories of people you know dying
resurrecting and all that kind of stuff
but is christ
at least the first claimed person to
have fulfilled that story in actual
reality
i think so i don't think i've seen
another story where it's not just that
because people say he resurrected but
christians don't just believe you
resurrect we believe that he gathered
all of death into himself and brought it
up you know into the father and so it's
like like i said there's no other story
after that right it's like that's it
like he basically went into death and
then gathered all of the all of all the
multiplicity all the way to the to the
constitutive elements and then brought
it up into heaven and so i don't think
that i don't if anybody has an idea of
another story like that besides the
story of christ i don't i've never heard
it yeah yeah i'd like to know if there
is
because it's really i find that symbolic
story very interesting of you know
christ gone down to
hades defeating death and all that kind
of stuff because even people all around
the world when they get
to really hard situations and i've heard
this of like an old one of my best
friends who lives in chile they have
crazy earthquakes and there was a time
where he was like a materialist atheist
socialist but then when that earthquake
came and he thought he was going to die
he went on his knees and prayed for
jesus you know and there's a lot of
those
kind of situations where people they
could be the most anti-christian person
ever but man when you're in a crazy
situation where you think you're going
to die
who else you're going to call i just
find i always found that part
interesting and i think that's kind of
what made me curious to at least explore
christianity is that special place that
christ has
because people don't call for buddha if
they're getting attacked by demons
you know
uh and it's just it's interesting
because people
even i actually want to talk to you
about ufos because i found even that to
be the case where certain
people have a ufo experience they'll
call out to christ and then
disappear oh really yeah i've never
heard that story i but i believe it i'm
not surprised i think i haven't tested
it but i've heard yeah exactly
i mean it seems pretty obvious by now
that there's at least a relationship
between
ufos and uh
and kind of these dark these kind of
dark principalities you know and and you
and the relationship between ufos and uh
and also psychedelics seems to be coming
clear and clear let's say um you know
and and it also it seems like it's also
part of the story like it's have you
ever seen uh alessa crowley's uh his
demon like the the the the creature that
um supposedly dictated several of his
books it's his this demon is called
eliath
it just looks like yeah elias or a
a-l-i-o-t-h
and elias looks just like a like a gray
dude he looks like a gray
and this is like
yeah and i think it's the first image of
something like that that anybody had
kind of ever seen
uh
but but he he has so he had this
encounter you know and and crowley and
the oto were
were really
part like they were trying to break
things open like they were trying to
kind of just remove the seals you know
um and i think they probably were
successful and right now
revelations eh yeah and part of the
chaos of what we're seeing is maybe this
kind of this opening that they
participated in and now there's a lot of
this stuff kind of flooding through um
and so it's interesting that you say
that that you've read stories of people
who pray and then the ufo experience
just vanishes i'm not surprised yeah
same with sleep paralysis or a bad
psychedelic trips uh
things like this and again these are
people who you can't even say it's oh
it's just placebo oh it's just bias
because it's a lot of times it's coming
from people who
if anything they're anti-christian so
it's like if any you know what i mean
like it makes no sense for it to happen
it's just funny like people imagine that
imagine what you what you said and like
people people stop thinking it's like
they say it's just placebo it's just
biased it's like okay well then
why don't you call to spiderman and see
what happens
and see if it's just placebo
it's like that's not how reality works
it's not true maybe there's something
placebo about it
but placebo is not arbitrary even if
that's part of it it's like you can't
just call to anything and then it'll
work it's like no it has to be something
that you believe in and that's something
which is
powerful enough to kind of be there in
your
story even though you deny it
consciously and so and so and so the
idea of just saying it's like oh it's
arbitrary it's prejudice like okay dude
you don't understand how these things
actually work it's like no they're not
they the reason why they would even work
even using the placebo argument
is not arbitrary right
oh yeah hundred percent
even the word just like oh it's just you
yeah i know that word
every time i said it's just that i'm
like okay it's just a projection
yeah i've caught you that's not it's not
possible like think of think of the
placebo effect you know think of of the
placebo effect if you get if you get a
placebo from your doctor
you know probably work but if like a
homeless guy walks up to you on the
street and gives you a pill and says
it's going to cure your disease man
it's not going to work all right yeah
it's not going to work and so it's like
placebo's not arbitrary it has a it has
a has a structure and it has a it has a
way to manifest itself and we can
understand it and it's actually part of
reality it's not it's not something that
you can just put to the side and say
this is not part of reality it is
because it works like it actually works
so
what do you think of uh these
have you got delve deep into like
these psychedelic entities that people
go into like let's say have you heard of
the dmt jesters
no i know a little bit of the machine
yeah i know about the machine l's a
little more yeah what are your thoughts
on that like what is that i find the
very i find the machine like uh let's
say i concept or the machine elf
experience very it's fascinating because
do you know like i do know about the the
the traditions of the book of enoch you
know a little bit about the book
i know a little bit about it i haven't
read it completely but yeah thank you so
in the traditions of in the book of
enoch the book of enoch is a book
that was probably written in the second
temple period and so it's like let's say
a little bit before christ uh came but
but refers to tradition
before the flood
is it non-pronounceable noah or is it
canonical so the story is that
no i mean it's canonical in some it's
canonical in the ethiopian church for
example and uh and it remained kind of
part of the
it's quoted in scripture saint paul
quotes the book of enoch several times
so the so it's not it's not fully
canonical but it's kind of part of the
lord let's say christianity
so in in the book of enoch you have
the the descendants of kane
they're the ones who develop technology
by the way in scripture you see that
that the descendants of kane are are the
line which develop all technology so
music
and then the arts and then cities and
and then metallurgy and weapons all of
this is developed by cain but in the
book of enoch you it expands on the idea
that you know it says the sons of god
went into the daughters of men
and then
from that spawn giants
and so in the book of enoch the idea is
that these demons these spiritual
entities come and they teach
technical skills
to humans
they teach them how to make metal they
teach them how to uh how to make weapons
they also teach the magical skills like
necromancy and they even teach them
interestingly enough uh like uh they
teach women how to wear makeup
uh which is very interesting because it
has to yeah it has to do with seduction
and it also has to do with kind of this
um using using um
a covering to enhance something which is
what technology is and technology is
basically makeup you could understand
that it's like it's it's like adding
something to you in order to give you
more power right you can understand
because once you understand what makeup
is it can actually help you kind of get
it what technology does so so these
demons appear to the or it doesn't say
how but they mix with humans somehow
okay and then they teach
these skills of making tech
technology and weapons and and
makeup and all these things um
and that is and the chimera is important
too so they they teach them how to make
hybrids
uh like different kind of hybrids human
animal hybrids and
you know
different different uh animal hybrids um
and that kind of
the excess of that is what leads to the
flood it's like basically things just
break down and then here comes the the
flood to kind of recapture the world and
so
the machine elves are super interesting
because it just seems like it's playing
out
it's playing out the story of enoch and
slaying out a book that was written
thousands of years ago where people
encounter these beings and these beings
teach them or show them
technological or technical patterns
that some i guess some people are able
to kind of apply in the world
and uh and so it's like the idea that
our technology comes from aliens is
actually even though like the way that
they do it in on the history channel is
completely stupid and and ridiculous
the trope of thinking that our
technology comes from aliens is not
completely stupid if we understand
aliens as just these these kind of
beings that
that are able to kind of manifest
patterns to people without discernment
and then we kind of move into these
these uh these kind of technological uh
yeah so so i think that it's very
fascinating because it seems to be
playing along
with what's going on and ai is
definitely part of that you know the
idea of these kind of embodied
intelligences mechanically embodied
intelligences it's like all of this
stuff is moving towards something like
what we saw in in the pre-flood
narratives you know
seems like it and i've had experience
with these uh kind of i don't know if
they're machine elves but
basically
it was all of evil and darkness
composed into one being but it had all
these mechanical parts like this kind of
soulless
mechanistic just
i don't know like no free will
determinism but evil yeah it's really
it's really bizarre
but when because when i've gone through
these experiences i i've noticed then
that
these principalities
they're it's like they're more
fundamental than us you know what i mean
it's like a layer
before creation or something like that i
don't know i might be
crazy even saying this but it really
does feel so overwhelmingly real that i
understand why people kind of get into
it but there's also of course the dark
side of it and i should be grateful that
i
tapped into the dark side early on and
not you know what i mean not tagged
along until later in life so yeah that
you that you kind of saw it and said
okay well i need to think about this
yeah it's like basically hell scared
scared me back into heaven sort of thing
it's like oh okay i want to go like
whatever the opposite direction is to
that
i'm going that way
and just live normal life you know
just human human life day to day yeah i
think i think that's very important to
be grounded you know because i think
when you get too lost in these spiritual
dimensions without having the grounding
it can be more dangerous you know
any spiritual practice i feel like you
know i feel like even christianity could
be dangerous if you don't have
that grounding and i've seen it with
people you're right with people who get
too inflamed with pride or something
like that and they become self-righteous
like that
typical you know i don't say that but
even the mystical practice of the church
like in the orthodox church we have a
mystical practice which is called
hesicasm or the jesus prayer and it's a
and it's a prayer which is repeated uh
and then
it's also
coupled with a breathing with a kind of
with a breathing which rhythms the
prayer you know um okay and like how do
you do this is this just a quick thing
is it like
you breathe in you say half the prayer
and then you breathe out yeah yeah okay
yeah and so this is like this is really
kind of the the basic structure of of of
orthodox mysticism and everybody does a
jesus prayer like everybody prays that
but there is an idea that some people
will
will pray the jesus prayer in a manner
that they become or the prayer
enters into their heart
and that they actually kind of the
prayer takes over their being and that
they they kind of become just the prayer
and so
there's even this idea that at some
point your heartbeat
rhythms with the prayer
and that your heartbeat becomes the the
prayer
and so
the fathers will say
don't do that like if you don't have a
guy like if you don't have someone to
guide you like do not do this it you
will become insane like it will lead you
to insanity if you
go in this direction if you try to kind
of do to pray without ceasing like to
just kind of because this is the idea
that they try to do is they try to the
monks basically try to become
constant prayer where their entire being
is kind of caught up in this in this
prayer uh and it leads to illumination
it leads to theosis to basically being
ignited with god but they tell you like
don't do it without him without a guy
because it's super dangerous and it uh
and it'll it'll make you it could drive
you crazy and monks go crazy you become
you go to you go to these these
monasteries you know let's tell monatos
and you'll just meet
crazy monks monks who lost their mind
because they just weren't they became
prideful or they just weren't being they
didn't they didn't accept to be guided
or they just did their own thing and
then they just
well it's funny how that that attitude
is so universal because even in the
psychedelic world let's say with
ayahuasca
a lot of people like no don't you dare
do this without a shaman and then even
to go beyond that it's like you've got
to be very careful which shaman you
choose
because again you're even in these new
age practices
most reasonable people are aware that
you are opening doors you know what i
mean and you have to be very careful
with what slips through
yeah even if something seems good it
might not be good it's hard to know like
how
can you explore these realms
uh smartly and safely or is it one of
those
best not to
mess with that kind of stuff well it
just depends on who you are as a person
i mean i've never i've never done
psychedelics it's like i i i can't speak
from experience i i
feel like
let's see from it from a more
traditional perspective it's definitely
more on the dangerous side
in the sense that the idea of a real
spiritual practice is is to be
transformed
right it's to actually
rise up in the hierarchy of being is
like through humility not through pride
but like through humility and practice
and and and spiritual discipline that
you actually become more like the angels
become more like god and so it's not so
much to just have these experiences of
this world but rather to kind of
participate and rise up in in the
hierarchy of being you would say you see
this image called the ascent of the
divine ladder
where you see uh monks going up a ladder
and there's christ
uh above christ is the goal right we're
actually aiming towards christ to become
like him to be united with him uh and
then there are angels that are kind of
helping along the way
but then they're also demons you see it
in the image like these demons are like
pulling the monks down and they fall
into like the mouth of hades at the
bottom of the image um and so
yeah their idea is not to either
experience the angels or experience the
demons right their idea is to aim
towards
the transcendent aim towards christ
aimed towards the place where heaven and
earth meet uh and then you will
encounter them along the way but
but that's not the per that's not the
point and so the problem with with i
think with a lot of the psychedelic
stuff is that people can
rip open the veil
and then move into this world and they
have these experiences but they're not
better people
but they're not more they're not freer
from their from their own demons they're
not free or from their own passions and
so
yeah so they're more in danger than they
would be if they if they would just kind
of stay in the normal world and
by saying that but look i'd be honest
with you i know several people that that
that did psychedelics
and then converted and then just became
christian
uh yeah
i've heard that that's that's the thing
that throws a wrench in the whole
thinking about this because i don't i
don't have necessarily a strong opinion
of psychedelics of this or that because
they're so mysterious and they have so
many different
outcomes for different people however i
would say that at the state that
humanity is right now it probably
would be more dangerous than it is good
uh but i don't know if that's
necessarily the psychedelics themselves
but just where humans are because we're
very prideful and very naive and can
fall into these traps you know
and also because we're materialists and
and so i can see it like i can totally
see it because it's like for all my love
jordan peterson like i love dream
peterson you know but but i think that
this is one of the dangers that he's
falling into it's because
it's easy to you can you can analyze it
right it's a mushroom it's like here's
the chemical formula right here's the
thing it's right there just take it you
eat it and there you go so it's like
it's super easy so so the most
materialist the most scientific person
can say like
this is like it's it's it this this
works it's a pill you take it you have
this experience you can analyze it you
can calculate it you can you can look at
the person's brain you can see their
waves whatever is going on and so and so
it seems like a kind of materialist
shortcut you know to the spiritual life
uh but i think that that's also why
why it's a problem like i think that
that's why it's a problem is because
you know
look at look at even like at the way
that
uh i don't know if you saw that
discussion you had with the guy who
wrote this uh this what is it like
i forget what it is there's something
about how much rooms are at the source
of our religions or whatever some book
about that oh yes i actually had him on
yeah yeah uh
the immortality key is that right i
think that's maybe that's what it is i
don't know but look at look at what
they're doing it's like so so think of
the mysteries of releasing you loses for
example right so you have this entire
ritual that lasts several days
and is extremely engaging and is like
sworn to secrecy you're not allowed to
talk about it there's a whole thing
around the entire mystery of elusive and
then maybe
at some point in this thing where they
come let's say to the to the edge of it
then there's a substance involved in the
experience
but now the materialist wants to just
say
well that ritual stuff it's all [ __ ]
it's the it's the mushroom yeah it's the
mushroom dude
formula that i can analyze and that i
can show you and that i can i can
measure and i can and so and so it's
it's just such a materialist way of of
looking at at reality
uh that even if
maybe in some in in some cultures
psychedelics were part of the process of
transformation of the person the idea
that they were the central part of it is
complete nonsense
it's complete nonsense and and it's and
it's super dangerous and it's such a
it's like a materialist
way of approaching you know these these
ancient myths these stories these
these patterns of transformation and and
i anyway so i i tend to really
be very cynical about about this stuff
hmm well even kyle jung was cynical
about it and it's because it's funny
because even myself a lot of psychedelic
people quote carl jung
like he's our lord and savior but even
he's like yeah beware of unknown wisdom
don't do psychedelics pretty much he
didn't say those exact words he did say
before of unknown wisdom but he was very
but then again man he went through like
a 10-year
psychosis so he's like yeah i don't need
to open any more doors
i'm good
[Laughter]
yeah definitely definitely yeah he also
had i think that problem where he wasn't
he didn't accept to be guided you know
and uh and there are there are stories
about jung like
uh you know even
even like from uh even not even from not
a christian perspective you know there
are stories of him you know going
to india but all but then refusing to
even to be guided by
the supposed masters that he encountered
there
and that he wouldn't even meet with them
like he was just
he's a scientist like in the end he
ended up and i think that
that he didn't like yeah he just he was
never like he he i don't think he ever
ended up being either a practicing
christian or an initiate of anything he
was just
someone from the outside who was trying
to
explain these things and then
got cracked open you know just got
cracked open is the only way to see
could you imagine that like going to bed
sleeping with a revolver under your
pillow and having these attacks by these
entities every day
i'm surprised he didn't like end up
killing himself man that's like yeah
that sounds like hell to me but i'm glad
that he got some knowledge out of it and
came out the other side thank god
yeah yeah yeah yeah well
here's what it is uh yeah jonathan i'd
love to uh just finish this off because
i know that you make a lot of videos
about like symbolism unpacking movies
and stuff do you ever do video games
it's funny because everybody doesn't ask
me to do video games forever and you
should
and then i did i did a video
it was probably because it it's also
maybe i didn't approach it the proper
way
i thought okay so
what what i should talk about an early
video game to show the pattern and kind
of how it was there from the beginning
let's say even the more complicated
games like superhead
yeah so actually so i did it on donkey
kong because i was moving towards oh
like the old video donkey kong i did a
video on a video on donkey kong and it
just totally bombed like nobody watched
it uh and then it discouraged me for
cause i wanted to do it on donkey kong
and then do it on super mario
uh as a kind of second a second step to
show how
it's all there in donkey kong but then
it kind of unfurls into mario and then
let's say mario becomes the
becomes like the template for basically
all the games we have now uh but uh but
yeah but then i just never made the
second video because it was because it
was a lot of effort to kind of to
to put it together and to write it and
to edit it and then yeah so you can find
it the donkey kong video if you want i i
think it was pretty good like i was
happy with it but maybe i will like i
might do it maybe maybe you can even do
like a uh something that i would enjoy
anyways seeing you do like a reaction
video to one of the more popular games
like skyrim or something like one of
these epic kind of fantasy
worlds that people are completely
obsessed with that have really cool
stories and symbolism yeah well i think
that like elder scrolls i think they
definitely do a good job at kind of
containing a world like they they
represent a world that is that is quite
is both very diverse but also coherent
enough that it really fits in that
almost it fits a little bit in that kind
of token
a token is the one who set by the way
tokyo is the one who said who set the
map for all of these things like
especially for especially for the the
the fantasy video games or the world
building video games it's really token
you kind of set the standard for that
uh but but for sure in in elder scrolls
they do a good job at
let's say embodying it you know um so so
yeah i think so but it's just hard
because let's say something like skyrim
it's like
it's
big about it's like this huge huge game
it's hard so
even the story itself is really big and
so
i think it would i think it'd be
difficult to do like uh kind of control
or break it down maybe like do breaking
down like literally one mission of a
certain story you know what i mean yeah
and you're maybe just choosing one and
then it goes
i think it could explode skyrim is very
popular you're very good at unpacking
these kind of myths so
just an idea you don't have to do
anything but it's something no no no no
no no no but it's not it's something
that it's been obviously people have
been asking me to do video games for uh
for a while for a long time and so who
knows maybe i don't know it's possible
it's also it's like there's so many
things to do too so it's hard to it's
hard to sometimes decide what i'm going
to do yeah i know you want to do all
these things at once uh yeah why why do
people play
something that'd be fascinating is why
do people
are obsessed with
horror games and stuff like that like
why do people get out of the way to pay
money to scare the crap out of
themselves
so why do people why do people like play
hard yeah just on horror in general it's
something that's been very fascinating
for me
okay well
horror
like horrors how can i say this horror
is a reality
there's there's a relationship there's a
little bit of relationship between
something like sacred space and horror
in the sense that
horror is a category it's always a
category which transcends the rational
right horror is like the irrational with
just kind of
smashes against the right like that
primal adrenaline sort of thing
yeah but also it's like something which
is
is unreasonable right it's it doesn't
make sense right
even the idea of a mass killer doesn't
doesn't make sense and then the more
imagistic versions of that i don't like
evil dead or whatever like these kind of
these kind of this
encounter these
these really really kind of
irrational forces that are extremely
cruel and that are extremely violent and
and that are basically will just destroy
the world it's something that it's
something that is
that can make us peek into the idea that
there's something beyond the rational
right it's called it's kind of like in
the it's kind of like in the wrong
direction you could say but not totally
because if you look at christianity
horror is part of
the sacred
right the cross is
in part it's not just horror but it's it
is horror
horror is in the cross
there's other things going on in the
cross but but horror is there and so
um
i think the difficulty
with [ __ ] is that it it's just in one
direction let's say it's more about
kind of encountering the monsters on the
edge of the world you could say
something like that yeah um
yeah so but but i but it's not it's not
completely uh
it's not it's understandable because if
you if you read even
the idea of uh there's a relationship
between awe and terror
okay
they're just in the experience
so think about like i mean you can
imagine it like just in a primordial
experience of kind of
encountering a giant warrior right
and this giant warrior like steps out in
front of you and you're like kind of
your 11 year old boy this like six foot
five
massive
warrior with a helmet like just steps
out in front of you it's like you're
gonna be a lot of things you're gonna
feel a lot of things when that happens
you're gonna feel
scared
impressed overwhelmed
like
let's say
frozen in front of this like this this
revelation let's say and so you could so
that's when you can kind of understand
this idea of the relationship between
let's say the terror of encountering
god or encountering an angel you know
like the reason like the joke on the
internet right right the biblically
accurate angels like there's something
about that that is that
the angel says when the angel says be
not afraid
the reason why he's saying be not afraid
the angel appearing to you is something
like a breaking open of normal space and
just like this like rushing in of of
this transrational space and so there is
an aspect of it which is
which is gonna be kind of terrifying and
so it's normal i think so that's why you
hear the angel say that because it's
like
they're also trying to signal to you
which
which side of this let's say which side
of this uh encounter that you're dealing
with you know
oh that's so true man those biblically
uh accurate angels are like whoa that's
like yeah
they're not really
they're they're going on purpose to like
make them really wild but like in in the
in the orthodox uh version of angels you
kind of you see something of that right
you do have the image of the chair with
the four heads and then the these these
wings with eyes on them so these are
iconographic like there are iconographic
versions of these of these beings uh or
like the wheels with wings and eyes and
stuff um but some of the memes like they
just go on purpose to make them look
almost like uh yeah it's like there's a
little bit of uh sensationalism let's
say in that for sure for sure but yeah
anyways jonathan i won't leave you
any longer i really appreciate you
coming on the podcast uh we had some
very interesting discussions well it's
good to meet you and i wish you all the
best on your on your journey for sure
yeah thank you thank you it's definitely
been an interesting one it's a long very
long journey because it's not like a
sensationalized one where you have like
an experience you're like oh yeah i'm a
christian some people do have those
experiences yeah but for me it's been a
very long
process of elimination kind of journey i
guess
i get it yeah well yeah so i wish you
all the best on that and also in your
kind of crazy
world of lockdowns you know oh yeah i
can wish we can wish for the best save
us jonathan please get me out of here i
wish i want to leave i really want to
leave
yeah
i feel the same here so it's not as bad
as you but i kind of i'd like i have all
these friends saying you know come to
texas come to florida
come to tennessee or whatever because i
wish other states but yeah all we can do
is
prepare for the worst and hope for the
best i guess that's right yeah exactly
well yeah anyways
thanks again for coming on the
on the podcast and yeah i hope to catch
up with you sometime in the future
great yeah and send me the link if you
when you put it up i'll show you oh for
sure for sure awesome all right thank
you all the best
god bless bye